جورجيا ساحه صراع جديده بين روسيا والغرب
والسبب قانون العملاء الاجانب الذي اثار
احتجاجات كبيره في هذا البلد المنقسم بين
روسيا والغرب القانون المثير للجدل الذي
يرى المتظاهرون بانهم امتداد للسياسه
روسيا التي لطالما حاولت فرض سيطرتها
بطريقه غير مباشره على البلاد مثل ما
تفعله الان مع اوكرانيا ينص على ان
المنظمات غير الحكوميه ووسائل الاعلام
التي تتلقى اكثر من 20% من تمويلها من
الخارج ملزمه بالتسجيل على انهم عملاء
اجانب تحت طائله الغرامه كما خلف القانون
ازمه سياسيه تنظر بانقسام في السلطه وصراع
داخلي في حزب الحلم الجورجي وايضا تململا
واستياء كبيرين في اوساط المتظاهرين
الغاضبين اصلا من دعم موسكو الانفصاليين
جورجيين بعض النواب في الحاكم ممن يدعمون
موسكو وفقوا على هذا القانون الذي يغذي
صراع النفوذ بين روسيا ودول الغرب غير ان
رئيسه البلد وقفت مع المتظاهرين الرافدين
لحل المشاكل على الطريقه الروسيه المعارضه
تعتبر ان القانون يذكر بتشريع روسي
يستخدمه الكريم لقمع الصحافه المستقله
ومنظمات حقوق الانسان وخصومه
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات
مسؤول التشريع في الاتحاد الروسي اتهم
بروكسيل و واشنطن بتنفيذ انقلاب غير
دستوري في جورجيا بدعمها للمتظاهرين موجها
اصابع الاتهام لبعض وسائل الاعلام
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه بالولاء لامريكا
غير ان رد واشنطن جاء مؤيدا للمتظاهرين
الرافدين لهذا القانون الذي يمكن ان تتبخر
معه كل مساعي الحكومه في توطيد علاقاتها
مع دول الغرب خصوصا الولايات المتحده